2023 is finally here and I believe it's
going to be a huge year for apple with
some releases that they've been working
on for years many years in fact that I'm
going to tell you in just a minute so
what I'm gonna do in this video is cover
every category of product that Apple
makes and basically tell you what you
should expect and when you should expect
those products to come so let's start
off with the Mac now in the first part
of the Year between January and March we
are going to be expecting a few
different Macs which I am very excited
for first of all we're probably gonna
see the 15 inch MacBook Air which has
been leaked for a few months now yes I
believe we're gonna get it with the same
M2 Chip and in fact I believe everything
is going to be identical including the
size thickness everything except for the
display size and the battery life it's
basically just like an M2 MacBook Air 13
inch but bigger and I think a lot of
people are gonna love that because you
don't have to go to the 16 inch MacBook
Pro which starts at twenty five hundred
dollars so that is going to be a banger
now we're also expecting the 14 and 16
inch MacBook Pros almost 100 guaranteed
I think is coming in March at Apple's
March event which they usually have
every year and it almost always has Max
related to that event and I believe
they're going to come with the M2 Pro
and M2 Max chips hopefully on three
nanometer we don't know for sure yet we
have to wait for some more leaks to
confirm that but those are going to be
some pretty nice Macs but don't expect
any major design changes because we just
got a redesign not too long ago and
another great Mac that I think a lot of
people are waiting on is the Mac Mini
and this time it's going to come with
two different chip options the M2 Chip
and the M2 Pro so that's finally going
to be a great option and for people
looking for a lot of performance and
apple silicon and now moving into the
spring and summer months the one Mac
that I think we could get revealed and
released is the Apple silicon Mac Pro
which has been delayed it didn't make
the two-year timeline when we were
expecting at the end of last year but I
think by the summer time we should see
it but unfortunately it looks like we're
no longer getting the M2 extreme chip
with four dies that's going to be
insanely powerful looks like we're not
getting that most likely it's gonna have
the M2 Ultra and that chip might be
exclusive to the Mac Pro only and not
coming to the Max studio just to make
the Mac Pro more special and then
finally in the fall I do believe we're
gonna get the M3 MacBook Air update and
that ship is going to be amazing because
it is going to be on three nanometer for
sure and that's going to greatly improve
the battery life and other than that I
don't think the design is going to
change because it just got refreshed and
redesigned but Apple might add in some
more features to make it a little bit
nicer and we also might get another 13
inch M3 MacBook Pro update or there is a
chance it could get canceled if we do
get that 15 inch MacBook Air now other
than that I do think we might get an
iMac Pro except I don't know when it
would get released but probably not and
we probably won't get a Mac Studio
update I don't think it's coming this
year and I don't think the 24 inch iMac
update is coming until
2024. so with that said let's go into
the iPad side of things for this year I
don't think we're going to get any iPads
at all until the fall because we just
got a bunch of updates between September
and October we're probably gonna get a
new iPad Air 6 and a very small iPad 11
budget iPad update probably just the
chip getting upgraded and that might be
all we might even get the iPad Mini 7
according to Ming shaquel it could come
as early as late 2023 but it could get
delayed until
2024 as well and I don't think we're
gonna get any iPad Pros until later on
in 2024. now moving on to the iPhone of
course they're going to be coming in
September and I don't think we're gonna
get an iPhone SE this year because we
just got one last year in 2022 and it's
on a two-year release timeline so that's
only expected in 2024 unless it gets
completely canceled now for the iPhone
15 lineup this year we're expecting a
full redesign which usually only happens
every three years just like we got with
the iPhone 12. I believe it's going to
be the same four models with the iPhone
15 plus even though it's not selling
that well I think they'll just drop the
price on it and there's even a chance
that Apple will Rebrand the pro Max as
the ultra and give it some extra
features now all of them should have a
flat glass back panel without the glass
camera bump at least in my opinion and
my renders that I created with renders
by Shailesh show off what it could look
like with this nice titanium Metal
finish for the Pro Models now for all of
the iPhone 15 models they will no longer
have any Notch so everything's going to
be with the dynamic Island and all of
them are going to have USBC ports except
the Pro Models will probably have faster
transfer speeds now only the Pro Models
are expected to get 120 hertz Pro motion
so that's going to be exclusive and
they're also going to get the new three
nanometer a17 ship which is very
efficient 35 more efficient so we could
see a huge boost to battery life and
that could destroy the competition now
the Pro Models or maybe just the ultra
are going to get the telescopic camera
up to six times and of course there's a
chance that the titanium metal might
just be exclusive to the ultra and it
could have a bunch of other features
with it as well now moving on to the VR
headset Apple's awesome headset that
they're working on there were some
rumors that we're gonna have a January
surprise event but now it's looking less
likely because of delays and because
it's going to be very very expensive I
don't think it's going to be that big of
a deal to regular consumers I think it's
going to be about two thousand dollars
so most people aren't going to be
interested in it but I think we could
get a reveal at WWDC in June and it
could get released later on in the fall
now as far as the earpods we just got
quite a few updates so I don't think
we're getting anything except possibly
an update to the airpods max headphones
and if they do update it hopefully
they're going to give it support for
lossless maybe even a brand new lossless
codec which is going to be very good
probably get new drivers with better
sound quality better active noise
cancellation and potentially some
different colors but I don't think we're
expecting any other airpods models this
year now as far as the Apple watch we're
probably going to get the series 9 this
year but there's been no rumors yet of
what we could be getting with that new
watch we might get the new blood glucose
sensor but it'll likely get delayed
another year or so in my own personal
guess for the Apple watch this year is
that apple is going to re-release the
Apple watch Ultra but in a smaller size
for smaller wrists but we're not
expecting any other changes to the
design it'll likely be the same even for
the larger model now as far as the Apple
TV we just got a really good 4 4K
version last year and it's really really
good in terms of the value especially
with the new remote that's amazing with
the USB type-c port I think it's a great
deal so I don't see any reason for Apple
to change anything this year unless they
decide to create a new inexpensive Apple
TV stick which was rumored a while back
but we haven't heard anything since then
and then finally there is the homepod
and I have a feeling that later on this
fall we're going to be getting a new
large homepod like the original but
upgraded with better sound quality and a
less expensive price however we have
been getting some reports that Apple
wants to make a hybrid homepod that
comes with a display and a built-in
camera similar to Amazon's Echo Show
which Apple would use with the center
stage camera technology to kind of track
you around the room when you have it
placed let's say in your living room or
a kitchen that would be really cool or
there's even a chance that it could be a
high performance Apple TV with the
homepod built into it but that idea is
less likely to happen so with all that
said it's going to be a huge year for
Apple especially with a VR headset which
they've been working on probably for
over 10 years and the Mac Pro which I'm
really really excited for now if you
want to see my personal recommendation
for which Mac to buy right now you can
check it out using the YouTube tagging
feature down below thanks for watching
click the circle above and we'll see you
in the next video
foreign